[Music]
blanca is with us or blanca in
rockford illinois how are you god how
are you guys thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help so my question is
i'm i just recently started baby stuff
number two
and i currently live with my parents but
the house that we live in i actually own
the mortgage on it
um it's under my name and i'm just
wondering i've been
thinking about getting my own place just
a rental but i'm not sure
with me trying to pay off debt if i it's
better if i just stay here i am
helping out with half of the mortgage
currently obviously if i
left they would take care of it um from
there
but well i mean to start with i need a
little bit of clarification
actually they live with you uh
i guess so yes you don't live with them
home
it sure has them though when i bought it
i'm sorry
say again when i purchased the home i
intentionally purchased it for them
to give just as a gift because they were
they in trouble what was the
thought behind it so they so
their credit isn't the best so they
couldn't go off and
you know purchase a home um under their
name so
i went ahead and did that for them
what's their situation now how are they
are they making an income are they
stable yeah i mean i mean they're
they're making an income um they've
never been the best with
money but they'd be fine if i
if i was to leave they could take care
of payments and stuff
basically though you have a rental house
your parents are renting for the payment
if you move out
it's not their house
yeah technically you're right no not
tech i mean there's no technical
i mean you own the house if i go down
the courthouse and look it up it has not
got their name anywhere on it it doesn't
have a name on the mortgage it doesn't
have their name on the title
you own the house and and if something
happens in the front yard
you're responsible if if someone gets
hurt there
on the property you are the one that's
liable if there's no insurance
right okay if the payment doesn't get
paid nobody calls your dad
right they call you
so this is not technical this is factual
okay i understand emotionally that's
what i was going to say you have
allocated this house to them i get that
but you need to grasp that this is a
real impediment this real problem for
your future
that you have this rental property with
some semi-weak renters in it
okay it's bothering me i love that you
love your mom and dad this like this
and that's all cool but we've got to
really say hey there's some
real risk here for you how old are you
i am 28 years old and what do you make
i'm making about 48 000 a year
and how much other debt do you have
other than this home that your parents
live in
i have about two thousand dollars in
debt
mostly student loans okay and how much
progress are you making on that
um i just started baby step number two
so i've only
paid off about like five grand so far
good that's more than you've ever done
yeah proud of you
very good thank you okay so let
here's what we need to do let's pan back
okay five years from today
you'll be 33. where do you want this
situation to be with the house and with
the debt
five years from today i mean for sure my
debt paid off
eventually i would like to purchase
another home
so i guess i would have to see about the
possibility of
either transferring that mortgage to
them
um yeah they would need to be able to if
we'd give them five years and say
you need to get your credit in condition
so you can refinance this loan into your
name and i'll deed you the house
okay right we've got there needs to be
an end to this that's
positive and the only way that happens
is if we hit create careful steps to get
there
so you're about to put mom and dad on a
budget and walk with them to make sure
they now
get good with money so they can get a
loan
because let's pretend you're 38 and you
get married
and daddy quits paying the bill
yeah your new husband's not going to be
real thrilled with this bill laying over
here associated with your parents
yeah and so this doesn't my point is
this doesn't scale well it doesn't
it doesn't project into the future well
today it's all okay
right you're safe they're safe
everybody's happy nobody's mad at
anybody we're not trying to rock the
boat
but i i just want you to think about
okay long term and then what are the
steps to get to where i want to be
long term yeah and i think having an out
of the house blanca is going to be
really wise
and i think because it's something as
large of a purchase like a home like
we're not talking about a car
or anything like that like it is a home
so giving them a few years out
i think is really is really smart
because i think you're going to look up
eventually and what what was intended to
be such a gift and so kind on your ends
and really trying to help in turn
may not be a great decision for you and
there's a point as an adult that you
kind of have to create those boundaries
and say okay this is my life
and you're not being unkind to your
parents by any means but what is smart
for me to do in this moment
so that way you get your stuff cleaned
up so that you you can help them later
if you need to but you just weren't in a
great position to do it in the first
place you didn't know it at the time
um and again out of the kindness and
goodness of you
really really thought that you were
helping and i think that the smoothest
transition out
um is that communication and having a
timeline for them to take over
yeah probably sounds like this mom and
dad we're about to have a little meeting
here
um love you guys did this out of the
goodness of my heart
we have to have an end game you have to
have we have to have an exit strategy
so i'm going to stay here for two more
years and continue to help pay part of
the bills
while i get out of debt during that time
you're going to get on a real tight
budget we're going to get your credit
cleaned up
because we got a five-year plan for you
to refinance and let's get the house
into your name i want you to have the
pride
of ownership i want you to not be living
in a house your daughter owns i want you
to be living in a house you own
and that's going to be great for you and
it's going to get it out of my name so
that i can move on with the next step of
my adult life
and i love you and we're going to work
together to accomplish these things i'm
staying for two more years nobody's mad
at anybody
but we are not going to just kind of
wander off into oblivion and pray this
all works out
because it ain't it ain't gonna work out
okay and what that does is i think that
puts pressure on the parents in a good
way though for them to
to get their dignity this may be a time
where you're like hey maybe under the
surface you've been enabling some bad
financial moves on there and they're
able to be maybe a little lazy so
they're not great with money
and they've kind of had the safety net
of you for the past few years with this
home
and when you put that pressure on to
make them actually behave and get on a
budget and get on a plan and they start
to win if they if they choose those
steps and become
financially healthy i mean for them like
that's that's
that's helping them you know in the long
run like that that's a beautiful story
there's a lot more dignity owning your
own place as you go into retirement than
living in a place your daughter bought
i mean there's just dignity to that and
that's a good thing for him
a good thing for her so i'll tell you
what hang on blanco we're going to have
a kelly pick up i'm going to sign all
three of you up for ramsey plus
we're going to walk with you and show
you how to do this okay we'll put you
through financial peace university get
you on the every dollar budget get mom
and dad on that
we're all going to work this plan
together you're going to live there so
you can all do it together it's awesome
and you can you know cheer each other on
on some wins and be able to head towards
some positive goals
but uh there needs to be a a catalyst
a little shock that changes the
direction of what's been going on here
you've changed your direction let's
change their direction with it so that
it doesn't hold you back
and so they get their dignity of home
ownership as they go forward
so that's that let's work together on
all that hang on kelly will pick up
we'll get you signed up
for all of that
good rule of thumb when you're making a
decision like this
where you're helping out somebody don't
look at it in the moment only
ask yourself how's this going to be
working 10 years from now
because most the time it's not